well it's happened again
this is the world that we now live in
Marriott International announcing this
morning that the personal information of
over 500 million customers 500 million
there's only 300 million people in the
u.s. obviously these are international
customers as well we're exposed in a
breach of its hotel and timeshare guest
reservation database the world's largest
hotel chain said it learned of the
breach on September the 8th and could
affect guests with stays going back to
2014 for 327 million of the impacted
guests the compromised data includes
name mailing address email address phone
number passport number Rewards account
information date of birth arrival
departure information reservation date
communication preference for some
customers who booked directly with the
chain and the information also includes
payment card numbers and payment card
expiration dates
despite the payment card numbers are
being encrypted Marriott officials could
not rule out the possibility that the
hackers were able to decrease these
details well they did hack you for 500
million people I suspect they might be
able to decrypt a credit card number I'm
just thinking I don't know I mean it's
possible Wow so if you're a Zander
identity theft customer and this is you
it's me stay there stay marry all
properties all the time when we travel
definitely got my debit card number
without a doubt of course I have to
change the stupid thing about every 60
days now anyway it's ridiculous but
anyway if you're a Zander ID theft
customer you're okay
because if someone uses the information
incorrectly uses it to open an account
in your name that is not you identity
theft
they ID fraud then Xander's identity
theft if you remember if your customers
assign someone a caseworker to it to go
in and clean it all up
doesn't cost you anything not even any
time that's there so and they've got a
million dollar in stolen funds
reimbursement on that so if you're not a
Xander identity theft customer you
probably should be starting today you
know really know why you haven't done
this already we are all of our family is
everyone that works here is I give it to
them as an employee benefit and buy on
the team so now if you haven't already
then activate your personal information
monitoring on yours and your ID theft
solutions page if you've got another
monitoring service monitor it for
goodness sakes do not reply to
unsolicited emails asking you to verify
personal information see once I get your
email then they're going to fish you is
what that's called and you know you if
you bite on the worm you're gonna be
there so you get a phone call or an
email asking you for information that's
no one does that in the banking world so
that's going to be you know someone that
has gotten this information and is
messing with you
you can place a fraud alert on your
credit file and probably a good idea to
do so and you can sign up for email or
text alerts from your bank to notify you
of any transactions that are weird or
off-base or even any transactions for
that matter you can set it all up to do
it but these days it's not a question of
if your information is going to get
stolen it's just a matter of when the
only possibility that you don't have
your information stolen now is you're
completely off the grid I mean you have
no cards you never use your social
anywhere on any application that goes
into any database at any time you've
never post your phone number or your
address on anything anywhere which means
you pretty much live in a cave
you're off the grid beyond belief right
and so today it is the identity theft
world is just a part of our world these
things just get hacked and they get
stolen so regularly that you have to
have something like these and their
insurance
ensure you know that identity theft
insurance in place and I've had it for
many many years and it's it just gives
you a lot of comfort because the big
deal is if someone steals your number by
the way
you don't owe money let's say they got
your name and your email address and
they with your phone number and your
passport number one else and they
wouldn't applied for a credit card the
credit card company didn't check to see
if there was a fraud alert on your
credit bureau they didn't even check
your credit they just issued the card
which they do about seven out of ten
times they issue it blindly then we
check about three out of ten
applications and so Wachovia or Wells
Fargo or chase issues a card in your
name with your social security number
and your email and all that stuff that
they stole from all these places and an
account is opened up in ten thousand
dollars is charged on it you do not over
the ten thousand dollars you did not
lose a dime the bank lost the money
because they were stupid and didn't
check your credit and and figure out
that it was a fraud and so just you know
what you'd but what you do lose is
hundreds and hundreds of hours fighting
with idiots at Chase in their
fraud-victim division and you're filling
out police reports and you're filling
out affidavits and you're trying to
explain to them that you did not open
this card and you are not going to pay
this card and it is an identity theft
scenario and you've just got to walk
through all of that over and over and
over again the beauty of having Xander
is they assign someone that goes and
does all that fighting for you and that
way you know you've got some
inconvenience but you don't you're not
out any money and you're not out
hundreds of hours fighting through this
so even if someone you know your
relative
your roommate steals your identity and
opens an account fraudulently without
your signature in your name even then
just because you know them doesn't make
you liable now you do have to be willing
to fill out a police report on them that
says I know who the thief is and some
people don't want to put their mother in
jail who stole their or have the chance
of putting their mother in jail
stole their identity but any mother who
opens an account and their kids names is
what's known as scum your scum if you
steal your own kids identity that's
about a scummy and low as it gets so if
I had my way they'd come pick you up and
lead you away and bracelets that connect
but they don't usually they usually just
slap you around a little bit and
metaphorically oh man it's just a nasty
nasty business but about 60 to 80
percent of identity theft is not stuff
like this
Marriott breach it's tough it's people
you know it's someone you know some
family member that's got a loose screw
and no morals and let me just help you
with this if you sign someone's name to
an application other than your home name
unless you have a power of attorney what
you have done is just called criminal
fraud that's what it is
so you cannot just open an account your
wife's name you can't just open an
account in your mother's name or your
kid's name unless you have a power of
attorney you can't do that that's fraud
criminal fraud scum this is the Dave
Ramsey show